another stern warning for all of us here
in nevada in the fight against
covet 19. if you went to any sort of
gathering over the holidays or over new
year's eve
state officials say you should assume
you have the virus
hector mejia is live this morning with a
closer look at the directive from state
officials
and what we all should be doing to try
and stay safe hector good morning
hey there good morning and health
officials suggest getting tested
anywhere between five and seven days
after exposure and today is january 5th
so if you went to any new year's eve
gatherings today or right now
is around the time you should be getting
tested and the state's kova 19 task
force says
we are seeing elevated levels of
transmission in virtually every corner
of nevada
officials say they know thousands of
people gathered on the las vegas strip
board downtown on new year's eve
but thousands more likely got together
with family and friends at private homes
that was you they say limit interactions
with others now
get a test and if you feel sick stay
home and isolate until your results come
back
and quarantine to the maximum extent
possible
it was a risk to go out and gather on
new year's eve the governor made it
clear
at this time we are focusing on making
sure people know how to handle
the next steps that was caleb cage the
state's cova 19 response director who
reminded everyone that manny can spread
the virus without even showing symptoms
so you should assume you are a carrier
until you get a negative test result
and the county is making some changes to
testing sites
to the hours at testing sites rather
starting next monday
but the bottom line is testing remains
free and it's an easy process
at several sites around the valley
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now